don't believe what you see artificial
intelligence is making it harder to
determine what's reality fake AI
generated photos are flooding every
corner of the internet and images are
getting more convincing by the deck lots
of folks got fooled by this phony photo
of the Pope including me decked out in a
stylish white puffy little jacket it
racked up over 30 million views even
experts weren't really able to
automatically flag it as fake
AI is also getting busted for making up
stories about public figures and even
citing news stories that never existed
Greg I have to confess I did see the
pope jacket I sent it to Emma I said man
that guy's got drip I'm not surprised
you would be fooled
[Laughter]
me neither but you know
you know it's funny we do we I I think
that like I think it's easy right now to
tell when it's fake because it's too on
the nose it's too improbable did you
really think this was fake immediately
yeah of course come on you don't know
that of course I well I talked to the
pope oh so uh yeah I called him up
that's where you were like I did my fact
checking yeah no I never go on vacation
to see the pope we worry about
artificial intelligence messing with our
sense of reality that's already happened
like with news you know the news was oh
look these days every story starts at
the end and people work backwards you
know and so we have an assumption and a
conclusion but that's not supposed to
how it's happened journalism once you
start with a story you make phone calls
but now the preconceptions are decided
beforehand AI I'm hoping I'm very I'm
I'm optimistic about AI that AI will
will be like old journalism where it
just takes everything and it just relies
on probability of what will happen and
you can't get by bias in that unless
somebody's controlling the bias well
what about the guy that was falsely
accused of something he didn't do by AI
that's not a very good start but but go
ahead well I was gonna say it scares me
let me go back so in graduate school I
wrote what is a terrible paper but it
was my concern at the time you'll
YouTube might remember this when OJ was
under trial there was a Time Magazine
cover and there was a lot of controversy
over it because they darkened they
shaded it right right and so my paper
was about how ethically that was wrong
that you should just have the picture
should be what it is okay so we are so
far past that now I live with a lot of
fear that every morning I'm going to be
the first one who reports on a fake
video or a fake photograph as if it were
real like I'm so concerned about it
because I don't know how you would do
that we're in a breaking news situation
how do you know immediately if it's true
or not and I'm
I don't really have an answer here I
just have a lot of concern I should
probably be concerned too yet I'm not
Dana
I think I know in my gut what's right
even though I fell for the pope story
thank God I didn't fall for that on air
Geraldo gotta slow down okay you gotta
gotta slow down you got to get a second
Source right you know
jacket the burden is on the believer uh
you know and and you know if you repeat
the then you're a bullshatter
you know it's uh you got to really be
careful now but in terms of the Pope and
the jacket it looked really cool on them
actually it did I liked it they had
pictures of President Trump out running
the law a lot of people fell for that
too Katie well the problem Heraldo is a
lot of these people who do this the
experts look at this and they can't tell
the difference so if they do this all
the time and they can't tell the
difference isn't that an issue I mean I
think the good news is that Greg will be
fine because he's been nice to all the
robots he's saying welcome welcome
you'll be good I know I saw this coming
do you remember that there's a story
about when they first the first motion
pictures and the first thing in the
theater they showed was a train coming
at the everybody in the audience got up
and ran right because they weren't used
to the technology I think it just take
we we get we're always behind the
technology and then we get in front of
it and then we become addicted to it and
then how do you get in front of a
technology that looks so real you don't
have I mean it doesn't have to be a big
puffy jacket yeah you could just say
it's fake it actually helps people like
Geraldo when they post things on the
internet and just say it's fake by the
way the one thing that wasn't fake the
Dalai Lama it's
was caught on camera asking a young man
to suck on his tongue yes that was not
AI generally no wait what's it that's
what I'm saying we knew and you could
tell are you sure yeah he apologized
yeah he apologized why did the Dalai
Lama say that exactly
did it say it he did it he said it and
he didn't
think of a ritual
running press
all right ahead toughen up America
Republicans want to kiss participation
trophies goodbye hi everyone I'm Brian
Kilmeade I want you to do me a favor I
want you to click to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page this is the only
way that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here on YouTube so subscribe right
now